citizens of the reject Nation Greg and what's your
name I'm John I think we just saw Black Adam at a
special screening at this building right here the
Dolby Laboratories building and uh we got to shoot
this quick before Burbank PD finds US hey Burbank
we're coming to Crime the hierarchies reviews
did you clear this with the city did you pay Black
Adam now if you guys haven't seen the trailer
Dwayne Johnson's passion project for DC and it's
it's like the dark version of Shazam that's all
you pretty much need to know been waking after
uh thousands five thousand years they said it
several times in this movie 5 000 years he wants
to protect his City conduct black Adam's been
awakened and so Justice Society of America
comes in because he's a he's like a nuclear
bomb waiting to go off Superman level threat
Amanda Waller's always warning about exactly
so the Justice side he sent in there um okay
well where to begin with this film I would say
that for starters one of the things that surprised
me the most about it was that post-credits scene
man if that wasn't ruined for you boy would it
have been awesome if it wasn't everywhere Dwayne
Johnson himself pretty much wasn't confirming
that whatever was put out about that post-credit
scene is true if it wasn't something you've been
told to expect it was a great post-credit scene
it is awesome we'll talk about it some other time
because it was like you know what even though this
was ruined for me it's pretty sweet yeah I'm
so excited to be here right yeah I still will
remember this moment in terms of the movie itself
the thing that really surprised me was how they
actually really let Black Adam be pretty violent
he is pretty brutal in the trailer they do have
that one line where he's having a standoff with
Hawkman and hawkman's like uh Heroes don't kill
he's like I do and in this movie he kills a lot
there's a lot of actual there's a lot of death
actually and I had that exact thought at one point
like a lot of people were dying right away he's
killing a lot of people in this movie and it's
pretty sweet and they get pretty creative with
bordering on that PG-13 to R rating you believe it
was cut down from an Arya yeah it's not like those
Sony movies you know uh where they're like he's an
anti-hero beer not really you want to be good this
guy doesn't want to be good he doesn't want to be
good and he's actually you know straight up I mean
granted he's not killing like good people and a
lot of the visual effects are pretty Dynamite like
there's so much of it that at times it becomes
very overwhelming at the same time time though
there are some very very impressive visual effects
with Black Adam like I actually really enjoyed the
way they chose to capture how he flies you know
that a lot of the way we're just sort of hovering
up forward it's kind of like playing a video game
character to a certain extent and I thought that
was great to bring it to life the Justice Society
of America everything with Hawkman looked awesome
Dr Fate he looked great right he looks incredible
yeah especially the way they realize his various
powers and the choices they make visually to
separate themselves from not being too much like
Doctor Strange yeah you know they actually managed
to make it so you're not even thinking about that
the music choices by Lauren Buffy which sounds
like a werewolf to me I thought the music was also
wonderful the movie itself was fine it was a fine
movie yeah I honestly it was pretty messy in a lot
of ways and I think like Dwayne Johnson actually
does do an all right job you know it was something
that I was very questionable about I didn't go all
I see is Black Adam when I watch this movie and it
didn't necessarily reinvent the Dwayne Johnson
wheel in terms of acting but yeah I mean he does
sell a much more hard line violent character
he doesn't have to rely on his charm in this
movie which is nice no he's not really a character
who Smiles like there's humor to be had with the
character but some of that is with its Fish Out
of Water qualities and the deadpan qualities yeah
yeah he's he's a very stoic character which which
is fitting for this guy Dwayne Johnson definitely
played a character you know what I mean was I
aware I was watching Dwayne Johnson for most of it
yeah I was aware the character he should play but
I appreciated what he was doing yeah I appreciate
that he really played a character instead of
just relying on Dwayne Johnson charm this is
gonna sound like a nitpick but it's not all right
I want you to think about this for one second
he wakes up after 5 000 years and he's speaking
English in a country where that's not what they're
speaking you know speaking English he's got an
American accent and no one's bringing this up
no one's questioning why it immediately pulled me
out of the realm of believability on what they're
doing because I couldn't move past that it was
ancient Shazam magic translates that's that's
the power they don't tell you about if that's
something they don't tell me they should have
mentioned no no yeah it is a little bit silly that
way it's very distracting and I think the problem
with Dwayne Johnson's performance here is while I
appreciate what he was going for I didn't really
feel the internal struggle they kept telling me
he's having no he's just kind of stoic the whole
movie is saying you could be a hero Black Adam
and he's like now I'm no hero and that's about
his first his whole internal struggle is I have
no problem killing people but I guess I have a few
people around me who I would benefit from working
from so I guess I should kill less people it's
sort of his whole journey you know while I think
that there's some charming performances to be
had like Aldous Hodges is Hawkman here yeah this
Hodges brings a lot to his performance like he's
really giving it his all Pierce Brosnan kind of
just slips into this poetic magician all-knowing
kind of role of Dr Fate I think he's perfectly
cast and then Noah centineo and quintessa Swindell
are in the movie well mainly mainly Cyclone is
yeah I think they gave a decent Charming amount to
Noah centineo he brought some humor to it that was
he was funny he's more of a character than she is
and yes he has bits that are identifiable and that
are fun to watch come back yeah it's like watching
Spider-Man she though is nothing in this film I
don't blame the actress I really blame the writing
of this film I wanted to see more of her yeah main
takeaway I had with the experience by the end of
it because at first it starts off clunky and then
it started smoothing out and I thought oh it's one
of those movies that probably gets better as it
goes but then it went right back into no this is
pretty clunky this is a messy movie it's very
very messy and it feels almost outdated with a
lot of the types of tropes they decided to play
into especially third act wise especially with
the villain it feels very perfunctory and com and
especially the villain first how cool the villain
looks it does feel like oh yeah that's right we
have to I guess have a villain in this that's
not just Black Adam trying to become good even
that quality feels underwritten that's the main
takeaway I had was the scenes that are not action
feel very rushed and there's so much information
being thrown my way that it becomes about just
keeping up with the most Baseline piece of here's
what you need to know about this character to kind
of give a [__] but you're not really gonna give
a [__] but you hear maybe you will but you you
probably won't yeah you probably won't and it's so
underwritten and the editing is just all over the
place well that's the thing is Yo Macaulay Sarah's
style like when the movie is Flowing I think his
style really works because he likes a lot of shots
a lot of editing a lot of coverage but when the
movie is you know it's a movie you could tell
has been reworked and when you're in one of those
patches his style does not help itself out so then
it feels extra messy at those times yeah it's a
brick it has like some of that cool Zack Snyder
slo-mo [__] that you you love and needle drops
and needle drops Galore which surprisingly worked
for me in a movie that I didn't think if you
told me needle drops were in here those scenes I
thought were fun they were fun needle drops to be
had I thought it did nicely to emulate Zack Snyder
in in enough ways to kind of make it cohesive with
what has come before in the you know Snyder verse
line of the DC EU but not so much that it's like
oh that's all they're trying to do or oh that's
the only idea they have and there's nothing else
brought to the table but it does feel very much
like no no we want to reinforce this Vision
because I wanted to walk away just going you
know what it was a schlocky fun but it doesn't
quite feel that way to me there are times of
it where it just felt kind of monotonous I think
there is like an equal amount of things that are
kind of fun and unique and especially you know
looking at Dwayne Johnson in a more harsh heavy
role you know like that's interesting but then on
the opposite side you have a bunch of things that
feel very requisite you eventually not only do
you have your villain tacked on but you also get
your requisite you know Army that we can easily
kill because there's vaguely Supernatural and
there's not going to be any blood or whatever uh
you got the family element of like I lost my wife
and kid and now I've got this surrogate wife and
kid I feel like they could have chosen some more
unique aspects I know the the thing with his
family comes from the origin of the character
but it's kind of mostly what his backstory is for
the whole entire thing you know you get some lore
with the Shazam Wizards and all that stuff but
it really feels like there's not a lot of meat
on the bone when it comes to the characters and
the most interesting idea the movie has is just
about the thin line between good and evil and the
way like the Justice Society looks at everything
in those terms when this is about you know a more
gray world and you know we need to be in charge
of how we see that Justice through but even that's
just like one conversation and it never comes back
and it doesn't really like imbue the movie with a
sense of weight it's just like oh I guess points
for having an idea and putting it in the movie
between fights the parts where the care seem to
most go into it was the action scenes because the
action's cool the action's great it's it's like
really great action and I feel like that's the
point that we're past with superhero movies now
that we at least ought to be where he is a little
bit more past the action scenes that's not one of
things you have to get right yes guys there's
this freaking Sky Beam at the end of this movie
that's what I mean by outdated there are things
that felt like this was the kind of movie I would
watch in the late 90s early 2000s the whole movie
feels like the Aries fight with Wonder Woman Kind
of imagine if you just took that part of act 3
and stretched it into an entire movie and that's
kind of what this feels like I didn't feel like
the movie really brought anything new other than
a cool new set of powers seeing that brought
to life was fun and there's there is fun to be
had the movie's messier than I expected it to be I
think it falls flat in a lot of areas that I think
you thought it was bringing dramatic heft to in
some ways it's about what I expected in other ways
it's a little bit of a letdown and in other things
they did better than I expected them to do it's a
little of everything it's a little bit better here
and a little bit worse here than I expected you
know it's a mixed bag yeah overall I like whatever
if you're gonna watch or go watch it I I feel like
you don't have to see it in the theaters even
though I feel like some of the action scenes are
worth more watching in the theaters than watching
at home for the first time if you're just watching
to keep up with the continuity watch it at home
if you care about any of the characters and if you
care about the action go see it in the theaters
because that's where the best parts of the movie
Will Shine the brightest but yeah it's not really
such a game changer that you gotta rush out didn't
see it you know no I feel like I've seen this
movie already I do too like this is about by the
numbers as you'd expect in every way and sometimes
flatter than I would expect but that's where we're
at it's fine it's a good skateboarding I have a
kid actors there's so many laughable moments in
there oh a lot of ADR too oh well what do you know
well you take things too seriously Greg all righty
well subscribe click that Bell are you excited
for the follow-up film where you know what the
follow-up's gonna be and I'm excited I'm still
excited for it I feel like it'd be cool Shazam